the only kpi I really focused on and the
only metric that I really bothered
myself with was can I get myself to 10
interviews in a week consistently over
the course of a four week span at the
end of the day we're dealing with people
a client is still a person they're not
going to bite you it's going to be okay
well let's just let's get through it
let's get them on the phone let's get
them for a coffee and understand what
they're about there's a certain sense of
open transparency that you have to have
when cultivating a leadership team of
understanding what does good look like
where do we want to get to and how are
we going to get there and everyone in
that team understanding the what how and
why behind every initiative is what gets
you moving forward welcome back to
another recruitment mentors podcast
episode on your host teaching azuz and
today I'm really excited to be joined by
Kareem Kareem's joining me from New York
Karim welcome to the podcast thank you
it's been a pleasure to be here very
excited as well and uh yeah ready to go
underway really excited to unpack this
journey that you've been on so just to
give people a bit of context like I
always like to do and feel free to sort
of add anything that I've missed but
Kareem you've built your career at faden
uh fading International within one of
their specific Brands Selby Jennings but
more recently become MD of fading
International particularly the the New
York
um part of the business
and over the last sort of decade
ultimately you progress your career from
being an individual contributor
recruiter all the way to where you are
now um as an MD so I think what I wrote
down here when we were prepared for this
was you was the 11th employee in New
York yep
um
and I think across the US there's around
150 people at the time but particularly
in the New York he was the 11th um
employee
and then you just overall over time
progress I think on here one of the
Milestones that we put was in
2016 because you joined the business in
let me go up here 2013.
so 2016 you ended up finding yourself
um being responsible for a 30 person
team then 2018 you took over sober
Jennings
um in New York and now 65
um people
235 people across a three-year span when
he was responsible for that and then
2021 he was then in charge of Selby
Jennings USA which was uh when you start
around 180 people which is now more 275
people
um and then now your actual from October
you're actually the MD of of fading
International
um in the American the specifically the
New York piece right right
so what what you shared with me is
obviously there's probably a load of
things that you find yourself doing
um and helping the business in but
ultimately you stop billing around 2016
and then really your your role now which
you sort of shared with me is really
focus on deploying people
um and getting people to build out new
markets and specific markets
um you're then also spending time really
investing in that leadership layer of
your business helping them training them
providing them with a blueprint just
really supporting the the leadership
team and and the future leadership team
uh also creating succession plans and
then the other part is just the maybe a
bit more recently we'll go into it but
just a bit more business strategy
overall for the New York office for all
the brands and ultimately maintain and
build a sales culture maintain fees
increase fees is sort of how we broke it
down so that's um that's me summing up
your 10-year career in three minutes
sounds about right
um so so hopefully that's useful context
for everyone but I guess the first
question the million dollar question
that we always like to start with and
I'm sure you really fought long and hard
about this as you've continued on your
journey but I'd love to hear your take
Kareem on in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you really
believe make up a highly successful
recruitment concern in in today's market
yeah absolutely so I would start with
the first being intellectual curiosity
um how I would sort of categorize that
as someone wanting to go above and
beyond to really nerd out or geek out in
their space in a sense right and don't
just learn what we teach you in these
four walls but go the extra mile to
listen different podcasts read you know
different Publications and news articles
and Outlets that you can sharpen your
skill set a bit
um also in terms of having conversations
with clients and candidates don't just
keep it high level transactional and
really try and delve deep and and be
intellectually curious to think about
how can I actually better my my skill
set and my knowledge how did this
conversation the the second thing I
would think about or you know I put that
category be resilience uh obviously
anyone that's in recruitment knows that
it's it's Peaks and valleys it's sales
through and through there's going to be
times where you're pulling your hair out
there's going to be other times where
you're popping champagne
um I think the
most successful recruiters are the ones
who have the toughest skin and can just
roll with the punches and not get
bothered or get knocked down very easily
um the third piece I'd say is
resourcefulness slash adaptability if
you will and what I mean by that is
someone who can think quickly on their
feet adapt to any different situation uh
think in a resourceful commercially
driven mindset uh to really capitalize
on any situation that they're in so
those would be my three
really interesting I love intellectual
curiosity how how do you try and
pinpoint that in an interview
environment absolutely so I think it
really you know starts with asking
brain teaser type questions if you will
um and see if people understand why
you're asking how can they you know they
elaborate in the right way
um I want to see examples of people
going above and beyond uh to learn a new
skill set if you will right if someone
is a self-taught you know guitar player
you know picked up a hobby and wanted to
you know go a bit further think about
something a little bit deeper uh those
are instances that stand out uh to me in
that sense
um really interesting so describe the
New York office when you joined yep like
because obviously it's been you've been
part of I think this is sometimes the
really great opportunity people get in
our industry is to go on this amazing
growth Journey with a company so you was
just to clarify the 11th employee within
the Selby Jennings brand so that this
was I was 11th employee in in fading of
all North America
um at the time I think we had about 150
people globally in Thailand uh when I
joined in 2013 the New York office
consisted of
I want to say
eight people in Selby Jennings uh at
about 2-3 in uh dsj or n10 supply chain
business uh so when I joined it was a a
pretty small room uh yeah it was the
infamous room with no windows um There
Was You Know A bunch of us in there just
doing quality recruitment
um as long as we could every single day
just trying to get the business off the
ground in the states
um and yeah it was uh it was definitely
a grind it was definitely a bit of a
different atmosphere to what I was
expecting but it was to me it was
incredible it was it was being a part of
something where
everything we put in you could see the
direct correlation of it coming out on
the other end so we're with hindset then
Kareem just curious
with hindsight
what do you think would like looking
back what were some of the I don't know
what what made that room special what
was some of the magic that was happening
in in that early period that now looking
back you're like you know what
I'm not surprised we've gone on to do
this so I'm not surprised some of the
things that we've achieved
with hindsight what were some of those
things that you think yeah really just
all came together and was a whole pot of
sort of ambition execution what are some
of the the the core ingredients that
Looking Back Now you're you're
definitely aware of that was in those
four walls yeah absolutely I think it's
you know that room and that business
really
set the foundation for what a lot of our
culture is today in New York as well as
across state in the U.S
and I think it it sort of starts with
hard work beats Talent when talent
doesn't work hard that's one of my my
favorite quotes and that was that room
through and through right no one there
was going to get out hustled or at work
by anyone I'll um and there was a
culture that embraced that and let us
really achieve that I'd say the second
piece was just the sheer ambition and
like-minded individuals in that room
together everyone was ambitious they
wanted to find you know a Sandbox where
we could realize that ambition where we
could actually
put that in practice and and reap the
benefits and the reward of our hard work
I think the third piece
I'd say comes down to
just again the like-minded individuals
in every sense the word we we wanted to
care for our clients we wanted to care
for our candidates we wanted to have a
mindset that doing good enough wasn't
good enough for us everyone was almost
aligned in the same direction of let's
go and Achieve our goals while also
achieving the team's goals the business
goals and taking the company one step
further together that I don't think you
can really
you know put a specific word on that but
it was almost like a feeling of it you
know you step into this room and there's
that that sheer electricity of okay
we're going to do this together and
we're gonna get there together
really interesting well um again just
thinking about the early period again
with hindsight any any advice that you
got early on from the experienced people
around you that that's really stuck with
you or maybe you've even found yourself
passing on to people who are alone in
their recruitment quiz as well yeah
absolutely I think for for many of us
joining equipment early on it it is a
bit of an adaptation understanding that
yes it is a sales environment but it's
not transactional sales I if you think
about
and recruitment as walking into a shop
and buying bottle of water and you know
transactions done here's my bottle of
water here's your you know your two
dollars we go our separate ways that's
obviously not what we do
um so some of the best advice I got
early on was really get to know the
people that you're working with on both
ends of the phone both the clients and
the candidates and understand that as
you make a placement or as you help move
someone from
you know Canada to the states or LA to
New York you're impacting someone's life
and once that sort of start to sink in
and I see that you know happening when I
I share that advice with some of my
colleagues you start to see that light
bulb moment go off or the the person
starts to turn the corner of like okay
this makes sense
it is bigger than just myself or
placement it's much it's much more
impactful than that
um
and then I have to ask as I was saying
to you before we started
a friend of the podcast is is your
colleague Oliver cook yeah so I asked
him for some questions yeah and what he
told me I don't know you'll be able to
fact check this I don't know if this is
true or not but
uh I said totally what would you love me
to ask him and one of the things that he
did say just touched on the early period
was he said I do believe that Karim went
eight months without doing a deal
it's correct doing the business when it
was a quite small team so yeah I have I
have to ask why the hell did you not
quit and how did you push through that
as you said it was an environment where
there was ambition I'm sure the
standards were high
you didn't see any quote unquote results
like the end result yeah right for eight
months how the hell did you keep showing
up every day putting in the work talk to
us about that because a lot of people
would have quit absolutely no it was uh
it was definitely a bit of a grind but I
think that kind of goes to what I said
early on just the sheer resilience
um yeah I worked very close with Ollie
for for a lot of years and I think to a
certain extent you know I don't want to
give them too much credit but see him be
successful
um in those early days for me and
watching him you know be a top bill in
the office and achieve all these things
I was doing the fundamentals as well uh
it made it so much more real and so much
more possible so I said you know what if
it you know why not meet why you know
what am I doing Ron
um
essentially what I was doing was was
focused way too much on a kpi and
driving a number to hit a number and not
really thinking about the process of
what I was doing
um and again the advice that I got that
I just mentioned before thinking about
the process not as a transaction sales
cycle but really getting to know the ins
and outs of the client the candidate
what makes them tick
um just a really good fact find if you
will start to level up my game and
interactions with individuals and then
that turned you know the the luck around
in a full 180 from bottom of the board
year one to top five globally or two uh
so it was it was definitely a learning
lessons at least
yeah it's interesting to tied it in and
then I guess I guess the final piece on
this end a lot of people and I'm sure
you have them in in your business now
and you've helped people but a lot of
people listen to this might be in that
period right now and I think what can
sometimes be difficult and I don't know
if you can relate to this but when you
are in the thick of
not seeing the the Billings next to your
your name you're putting in the work
you're doing the activity you're just
not it's not quite clicking you're not
quite seeing the results and when you're
in that you're in the trenches it can
definitely be hard to see light at the
end of the tunnel right and it can be
hard to see that it like see where it
that it could turn around do you get
what I mean so I guess just to sort of
tie that together again because you went
through that for people listening that
might be in that right now or might be
really struggling what would your advice
be to them that hopefully would help
them understand if they are on the right
track or uh if you keep doing this then
there is a good chance that you will
start
um seeing results because I think as I
said it can be really difficult to see
the light at the end of the tunnel when
you're in the thick of it you're not
getting the results that you'd hoped for
what would your advice be yeah
absolutely so
where I sort of walked it back was stop
thinking about the result
and the result is obviously getting a
placement across the line and seeing
that money come into your pocket but
again that's a result you can't control
the result and hitting numbers hitting
kpis on a day-to-day basis right you
can't just snap your fingers and boom
there's 10 CVS sent out the door boom
there's three new jobs pulled today that
comes from action and the actions I
would focus on is really what am I doing
every single minute of that day that's
going to get me one step closer
to actually achieving the result of
hitting a kpi
and as those kpis start getting hit and
start stacking up with good quality then
the result of a placement will come the
second piece to it was the only kpi I
really focused on and the only metric
that I really bothered myself with was
can I get myself to 10 interviews in a
week consistently over the course of a
four week span so I wasn't thinking
about where's my next placement coming
from or what am I doing there it's all
about how do I follow my specific model
that's going to get me to a consistent
four-week period of 10 plus interviews
each week
thanks for sharing that because I think
it can be overwhelming can't it because
we could have
a number of calls made number of BD
calls made uh first stage interviews
um Discovery calls I don't know there
could be a whole bunch of different
things that we're aiming to hit but I
think oftentimes what helps a lot of
people is really making it simple and
for you this sort of leading indicator
was if I aim to get 10 interviews and
I'll make that happen and I really focus
on the process over time
I keep getting better at those things it
should then get to the result that
obviously we're aiming for yep
absolutely so that that's a great
Insight so let's talk about leadership
then because that's clearly where you've
really excelled I know you just said
there that you went from as we've
discussed to then becoming the within
the top five globally yeah
but I guess actually to be fair I won't
let I'd be silly I think people would be
annoyed at me if I didn't ask you about
that actually
so
I guess what people would want to know
cream as you can imagine you've you've
you've done a really good job of sharing
some of the things you had to learn the
hard way
but I guess again with the the sort of
uh with the pleasure of of hindsight or
the ability to with hindsight
what were the the main things that kurum
was doing differently
compared to uh when you was in that top
five compared to uh when you won that's
obviously what people want to know and
feel free to go granular here we could
talk about the things that you did
differently when it comes to building
your brand with with your clients and
Prospects anything that comes up for you
because people want to know how the hell
did cream go from not doing any deals
for eight months to then over the next
two years becoming the top five globally
which clearly would have been a very
very competitive leaderboard with the
amount of people uh that fading would
have had across the the different brands
globally yeah so what comes to mind when
you think like what did I really double
down on and what did I do differently
compared to Kareem in the first 18
months of his career absolutely so where
I doubled down was again the hard work
piece right I just backed myself that if
I you know came in 30 minutes earlier
stayed 30 minutes later I would have the
apprehend on that I was getting to add
response before my colleagues and
getting people clear for new jobs before
anyone else could I was pulling leads
from people before anyone else could um
that was the one I'd say constant that
stayed with me uh where things really
started to
to turn the corner was when I started to
dive deeper into my market and when I
joined the business I was creating the
risk management space
um and full transparency I didn't you
know go to university for risk
management it was it was something new
and relatively foreign to me I knew
where it sat within the world of
financial services but it was a space
where I had to go out and want to learn
and and not just depend on my leadership
of the time to teach me the nuts and
bolts of everything
um
and I'd say that the third piece that
was a pretty drastic shift was
understanding that if the clients or the
other people who are giving us these
mandates who are giving us these
searches who are essentially footing the
bill in terms of one of successful
placement is made they're the people
writing the check let me get closer to
them let me actually understand what
they need how we can partner better
understand their business how to pitch
it properly I started to build repeat
business and repeat clients and that run
in year two for me really came off the
back of having probably four to five
really strong relationships where there
was multiple placements made in a very
uh you know short amount of time
interesting so again coming back to that
intellectual curiosity and really
committing to learning as much as
possible about your Market
and then as you said realizing that yeah
doubling down on the client
relationships and getting good at that
interesting so I guess let's as we're
talking about it let's just bring it to
to today then if that's okay yeah
because I think you're in a really
unique position now where you are
cultivating a high performance culture
brilliant and I think one of the things
that the ollie shared with me
um is around how you've got in the New
York office you've got some real
High performers I think he shared me
that this year you've you've had over 10
people in New York do over a million
dollars in Billings yep and and most of
these people have around like two to
four years experience
so all you shared about me so I think
this would probably be a good good time
just to I guess fast forward to today
because things have obviously change
evolved I don't know you'll be able to
tell us yeah the core of it might still
be there but particularly I'm sure those
those million dollar billers a big part
of them being able to achieve those
sorts of numbers is going to be around
getting really good on the client side
and cultivating those relationships
building repeat business all those
things so I guess the question I have
for you
um with what you can see going on in
your office what has continued more
recently to be the sort of most
consistent and efficient way of building
business signing new logos building
repeat business what has ended up being
the real principles that you feel those
High performers and your forwards have
continued to implement and and execute
on that you things really enable them to
achieve those sorts of numbers yeah
absolutely so
I think it starts with building foul
weather relationships and whether by
that is not just approaching a client in
a transactional way of
you know hello client are you hiring yes
no no okay cool thank you very much
leave leave you alone yes let me just go
and get a job where and then kind of
walk away where
where I think those individuals have
really excelled is that they've built
relationships where they're embedded in
some of these companies where we move
from essentially a spot business
partner
to a trusted resource and extension of
that internal Talent acquisition team
and it's not about us going and sitting
on site with an earth like that but just
getting to know people for who they are
for people understand what makes that
business take what makes that Talent
acquisition partner in-house
happy what they want to see and again I
think it's it's a whole different
mindset shift
around how to approach a client
that's elevated those individuals so
quickly and then obviously off the back
of that you're able to you know sign
better terms because clients want to
essentially pay you more to have more
attention on them and to get a better
product and a better quality service so
just again going back to what I said
early on for us doing good enough is not
good enough right we take a lot of Pride
and Astronaut work and know that
anything that leaves this place is
an example of who we are and sets the
precedent for What You Know The Faded
businesses the selfie genetics
businesses or whatever whatever you know
brand uh
so we really try and make sure that it's
our best foot forward every single time
so let I just want to peel about the end
on the bit on this if it's okay yeah go
for it because because I'll be honest
with you I think a lot of people listen
to this would probably have aspirations
to become
or even say to people like that's what
they are to their clients but it's a
whole other thing actually achieving
that and being that
so I guess
what I want to ask you and if we can go
a bit granular here
like I'm trying to understand how they
actually get to that position definitely
I mean because I think a lot of people
will probably that listen to this will
be aware that that's where they want to
get to where they are that trusted
resource there are extension of their
business right but they may be
struggling to get to that point it might
be that
um I don't know they're not asking the
right quality of questions or it might
just be a mindset shift and they're very
tunnel visioned on Kareem has told me
that he's got this job so I'm just going
to focus on asking questions around that
rather than asking questions like why
are you hiring for this person what if
happens if we don't get this person in
so like what what do you think that
those people have done differently and
how have they like really got to that
point
um because a lot of people want to get
to there but I think um the struggle
right so I don't know how would you ball
that down and I'm trying to get you to
go a bit granular here yes but I don't
know what what comes up for you on that
because I think that'll be really useful
for people one like how can they
actually get to that position right so
yeah I think it's a it's a combination
of factors one I'd say is well
internally for us Learning and
Development and our l d team is you know
amazing we have a lot of individuals
that help our Consultants at different
levels and stages of their careers so
people within that two to four year uh
span will take on essentially three
different courses uh through lnd that's
gonna essentially be the fundamentals on
how to mushroom accounts and how to get
closer to a client
ultimately what these people are doing
differently is the mindset shift right
it's it's taking a step back and
realizing I don't need to get a hard and
fast wind today I'm not looking for a
client to say yes to me today here's a
job
go fill it it's about understanding that
what we do is building excuse me is is
putting together a process and building
Rapport over a period of time
and this can come down to
you know questions about you know what's
the next six months look like for the
business right I'm not really interested
in hearing about your plans today
but you know if you're if you're a
hiring great if not tell me about what's
coming down the pipeline over the course
of the next three to six months right
where where are the biggest pain points
for you what have other you know talent
agencies and recruitment partners that
you have done well that we can emulate
or things that are missing that we can
maybe fill that for and but yeah I think
it's it's something pretty generic
obviously trying to you know fill the
void and and remove the the thorn in the
client's side but
saying it and doing it are two different
things and
I'd say one thing that we we really do
well is we want to start in in very
particular Niche verticals right we
don't try and be every and anything to
all clients we start in a very narrow
piece of the market that we know we can
deliver on
and it's almost about putting your money
where your mouth is so if I say
something to a client I don't want that
to be an empty promise it's I could do
this I will come back to you in the next
12 24 40 hours and you will see the
tangible product result so that's where
I think that credibility starts to build
in
yeah no I appreciate you sharing that I
think yeah I do think a big part of it
is the mindset piece
and the identity shift and yeah not just
focusing on getting that that that new
new vacancy win and like you said taking
a bit of a step back but I think what
underpins all of this there's no way for
anyone listening because we've done a
bunch of
um sessions on successfully landing and
expanding
um at recruitment mentors and what
underpins all of it is what Kareem is
saying which is you have to do what you
say
like none of you will be able to no none
of you will be able to continue to grow
the amount of money that your customers
spend with you and the trust that you
build with them and the equity that you
get with them if you're not delivering
and you're already doing good
recruitment it's then about combining
that with asking smart questions not
just being so tunnel vision taking a
step back and getting really good at
understanding the problems that you
solve for them and got asked questions
around that rather than like yeah just
about that one particular seat and that
one one job vacancy right
um so awesome I know we went a bit
grander there so hopefully that'll be
helpful for people but let's go into
let's go into leadership then
cream because that this is definitely a
journey that a lot of people end up on
in Recruitment and can oftentimes be
extremely difficult so why don't I just
start by sort of saying I guess firstly
just to get maybe some of the core
principles that you've developed over
time
like how would you approach leadership
differently if you were to start all
over again because I'm sure you've had
to learn things potentially the hard way
so if Kareem was to start his leadership
Journey right at the beginning maybe
around 2016 when you started finding
yourself
um leading 30 people or so like is there
anything that you would do differently
knowing what you know now because you've
clearly really really
um grown your teeth in leadership now
and clearly it's something that you've
excelled in so talk to us a bit about
that if you have anything to share so
I'd say that
to start off definitely know yourself
know what know who you are what you're
about what you stand for what your
principles are
what's the overall mantra for your team
in a sense and
I don't think those things should ever
waver
with who you bring in
but if I had to go back and and be a bit
better in 2016
I would recognize that
you can't lead everyone in the same way
not everyone's going to get excited by
the same things and even if you assemble
a team of 30 people that all buy into
you and what you're about and what the
main mission is
how you deliver that information is
going to vary person to person how each
individual receives feedback is going to
be different
um
and the style of which you have
difficult conversations has to be done
in a pretty thoughtful way
to make sure that information lands
correctly that was probably the biggest
learning curve for me well I thought
that I had everyone
everyone should think like this and
let's just go in this Direction together
and how could someone not see this
picture as clearly as I do once I got
that it started to work a little bit
better from a team building perspective
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast Partners Vin
cherry and Source breaker because you
listen to this podcast you were able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out vincere who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
yeah it's a great Insight how you know
what I'm probably gonna ask you now
how can people do that because that's
hard right
like how can you how have you got better
at are you making are you creating
intentional space so Kareem can learn
and find out how Hisham the biller or
Hesham the manager likes to be managed
what are you doing to collect that
Nuance or context that you obviously
need to be the best leader for them yeah
how have you got better at understanding
that because that's difficult
that to me it really starts with the
interview process right when you're when
you're bringing someone into your
business that
for me that that's that's alarm Bells
going off first things first who is this
person what are they about how they
learn how they like feedback and
understanding what makes them take from
a from the gecko
um
I think in addition to that when
someone's in the seat remember that we
are a people business and any business
that has individuals and people in it as
a people business we all have to treat
our employees as numbers and that's
something I've never done and never will
do right it there's a there's a human
that you're working with get to know
them understand why they're here what
they're doing it for what is what is
their day-to-day about what are they
like what don't they like let me hear
about your goals for the next six months
in the next six years and if they need
help crafting those you can actually get
in the weeds with them and give them a
bit of a road map and
one of the things that I've I've used
along the way is working backwards in
reverse engineering goals so if someone
says I'd like to buy a house in two
years let's figure that out and walk
that backwards of okay every day from
now until that to your mile marker what
do we need to do to make that a reality
so
that I think is something that's pretty
easy for people to do is just take 10 20
30 minutes out of your day maybe once a
month to sit down with each one of your
team members and understand what makes
them thick
um
and then I'd love to get your take on
like you're you're in a really
competitive business internally
um so I always like to ask this but like
what what do you again maybe with with
hindsight what do you think Kareem did
to be the person that did get the
promotions and you continue to go in the
right direction because I'm sure there
would have been other people within
those four walls that maybe had their
eyes on one day becoming an MD or these
things right so you've spoken a bit
about how you've had to yeah what you've
had to learn in leadership but what what
also do you think that you've done to
really make sure that you're the person
that gets those promotion that gets
those extra opportunities extra
responsibilities I think that would be
good advice for people to listen to this
also have those aspirations yeah
I think in in anything in life that you
do right do it properly is something
that I've always been told right
don't just do something halfway and
expect a good result if you gotta do
something do with care
take your time be patient
and
the main thing
I think I've done or the the mindset
that I've adopted early on was always
thinking my of myself as a business
owner
and a a major stakeholder in this
business and that any money coming in or
out
was essentially by looking at it as
essentially my own money
and that level of care of you know is
there are there enough different kinds
of tea in the kitchen right are people
happy when they walk in do they like the
colors of the walls right am I am I
taking care of every my new detail
in my team in my office and showing them
that I will do anything for them as long
as they meet me halfway and show that
same respect I think that essentially
has built a culture where people can
rally around that people know that I'm
fully 110 percent vested in their
success in the business
and off the back of that you then see
the success and results
did you
the promotions that you did get did you
ask for them or did they come to you uh
they came to me
really yeah but did you ever because I
think this is this has been an insight
and other conversations where
I think so I'm sure you've seen this in
in your four walls where people can
do uh perform and expect
but an Insight that we've had a couple
of times is why don't you instead find
out what you need to do and get clarity
on what cream needs to do to get that
promotion or literally be really
intentional about hey I want to be here
in three years what do I need to do or
what do you need from me for that to be
a possibility did you ever do that to
really get an understanding of what
Kareem needed to do and be rather than
just doing yeah having that mindset and
then just expecting that things come to
you because they don't always that
doesn't always happen yeah I know I
agree with that and I think that again
something around the failing business
that I've loved and respected from day
one and you know having you know early
on my search when I was looking for you
know a role in recruitment there was you
have two three businesses that I was
looking at fitting honesty was one
another one that I chose and the thing
that I loved most about fading was that
you could see the progression and the
way you needed to do from day one on the
first day of the business I knew exactly
what I had to do to get to director at
some point I knew it was going to take a
few years to get there but it was pretty
blatant in terms of the the layout now
one of the things that we do with with
our Consultants pretty much every
promotion cycle is stop and break down
where they are where they want to get to
um and set the tangible goals and
metrics that they can control over the
course of the next 12 months to reach
that next Milestone so
that's the reason why no one really ever
has to ask for a promotion it's it's
basically spelled out in black and white
of if you do these things you will get X
reward or you get X promotion
um and then again right it's it's
putting your money where your mouth is
rather than saying oh can we make a case
kind of you get over the line on this
promotion I didn't quite hit this
it is what it is and it's not what it's
not and I think that's the easiest way
to just be in a truly meritocratic
environment
yeah and I like that and I think that
that's sometimes a lot of companies
sometimes don't make the effort or time
to give everyone that Clarity because
that is one of the biggest frustrations
right when working for a business if you
think you need to do something to get to
a certain promotion or something that
you're driving towards you get there and
then you're communicated with to say
actually no you need to do this or it
wasn't clear right and that 100 will be
definitely a reason why some people
leave certain companies and move on so
let's talk about like what I'd love to
just get your your take on a lot of
people that listen to this that will
have aspirations to grow their
recruitment business I know and one of
the absolute fundamental things to make
that a possibility is the leadership
team
um and cultivating new leaders from what
I understand about fading and getting to
know
um only a bit of knowing a bit about
your business obviously it seems like
you guys do a really good job of
homegrown Talent yeah and bringing a lot
of people into your business that don't
necessarily have recruitment experience
is that fair yep that's correct so so
like talk to us a bit about your science
philosophy around turning those people
that never done recruitment before to
performing to then being your Future
Leaders like what what's the science
behind that how are you really making
sure that
um yeah your your um yeah growing that
leadership team rather than relying on
going to Market and hiring hiring
experienced people like what what's
what's your views on the science behind
really cultivating that really important
leadership layer in your business and in
the New York office absolutely so I
think
to grow a leadership team you need to
make quality hires first thing to bring
those people through and in an authority
fashion
um and I think that comes from a
continuous uh effort from our lndt that
helps grow individuals into True Market
experts uh it's our model our operating
model day-to-day in terms of what does
good look like and how do we achieve the
results
um that we do and how does someone go
about their day-to-day and
I think as someone moves into leadership
if it really comes because they have a
desire to make a wider impact on the
business versus just the role in
individual buildings and they see that
there is a career uh Runway and and
track and path forward
to help shape the future of a team
a lot of the people that we bring into
the business are as I mentioned
ambitious they have an entrepreneurial
mindset and they like the idea of
essentially running their own small
business in a larger business and
as we grow leadership teams I think the
biggest thing is making sure that that
cohort of people
have a good working culture as well
right I think one of the things that we
did very well with with the Selby us
business is that every cell b local head
to the different regional office we have
and the Team Heads as well all got along
right they were in constant
communication probably speaking to each
other you know at minimum two three
times a week and
there's this a certain sense of open
transparency that you have to have when
cultivating a leadership team of
understanding what does good look like
where do we want to get to and how are
we going to get there right if I had to
break it down to three things as you
know what how and why and everyone in
that team understanding the what how and
why behind every initiative is what gets
you moving forward
yeah and that's going to be my next
question because what you've clearly had
to evolve and get good at which I feel
like you're talking about here when you
say that what how and why yep
is how have you then got better at
managing managers or leading leaders
because now for you to scale and to be
in the position you're in you're now
having to lead
yeah like like through those people
right or like manage the managers
however you want to call it so is that
is that what you would ball that down to
that Kareem has had to get really good
at clearly communicating to the
leadership team the the what how and why
like how have you got better yeah talk
to us a bit about that because I think
that that can also be difficult like how
how have you got better or have you
approached managing managers who then
obviously manage their own team yeah
absolutely so I think managing manager
is probably one of the trickiest rules
that you can evolve into all right sorry
yeah go for it uh oh sorry wait two SEC
sorry
[ __ ] mate someone just sort of opened
my door and give me a delivery even
though it's not for me anyway
good let me uh let me ask you that
question again if that's okay
so and then we'll just carry on um are
we right for time by the way yeah that's
fine all good all right cool
um so yeah as as I was saying cream like
you've obviously would have had to get
better at managing managers that's also
a really difficult task to manage people
who are then managing other people
because I'll be honest I have spoken to
a lot of people in that leadership there
and that can end up being a quite
learning position so quite like what
you've said there around making sure
that cohort of leadership or that
leadership layer are speaking to one
another they know that what they know
how they know the why so talk talk to me
a bit about that in terms of how kareema
has had to get better at managing
managers and and yeah managing through
those people yeah so in terms of
managing managers right as I said it's
probably the most challenging
transitions that that anyone can make
what it really boils down to is getting
people to buy into you early on and
having the respect for what you do and
I think in any sort of recruitment
business you you earn respect in two
ways uh on the sales floor one is what
the scoreboard says and your track
record can you show that you've been
successful in the past you've built good
teams or you were a good biller there's
some sort of scoreboard behind that you
can point up the second way you you're
in respect which I think is way more
impactful is what you do for people and
I think inherently everyone is selfish
to a certain degree
with any change comes the question of
what's in it for me and if I was to
transition to go and lead a new manager
and have to get them good at coaching a
team and developing their new their
business they're going to understand how
is Karina valued what is he going to
bring to the table or what has he done
for me that's going to be different or
new that's actually going to help me
succeed so being able to identify that
early on and one of the things that I do
is just identifying essentially three
things that
the the teams can hold me accountable to
day in and day out and on the flip side
three things I expected them and just
leveling expectations from day one
now again one of the hardest parts of of
managing through somebody else is not
rolling up your sleeves and
circumventing them and going straight to
the problem
um or going straight to the consultant
that needs help it is about having a bit
more patience consuming understanding
framework and guidelines that you've put
in place and giving people Trust of
you know the the ability for them so
that you trust them to go out and
execute on task and if you say cool
we're going to go in this direction I
trust that you're going to get the job
done
giving them that that outlet
um that's always been sort of the
mentality the methodology behind it
what could be just quickly what could be
an example one of the things that you
could add value to them I'll do a lot at
the you yeah you're making a two-way
thing yeah rather than feeling like
Kareem is just busting my balls and
getting this doulas with his uh the
legwork right what what's typically one
of the things that they hold you
accountable to out of Interest a lot of
it comes down to helping with time
management uh most of the team leads
that I work with are you know running
businesses of let's say
10 to 20 people and they may be tasked
with doubling that over the course of
the next 12 months and running a team of
10 is much different than running a team
of 30. so
the the value add that I could give
someone is sitting with them and showing
them well this is how you're going to
spend your time this is where you may
put your efforts try this methodology
instead or use this system to keep
yourself organized
um a lot of it as well it comes down to
getting people to be more proactive with
their thinking versus reactive and being
better planners and as that's just
getting getting your week organized
before the week even starts one of the
things I do religiously is that I won't
I won't leave the office on a Friday
until I've set together a plan for what
my Monday morning looks like I've been
doing that for the last you know eight
years as a consultant as a team lead as
well uh and it's made a drastic
difference in how unable to execute
effectively uh first thing in the
morning on a Monday and carry out that
week in a positive fashion
yeah that is the I've given this out a
lot that is the number one top
management tip or habit you want to
implement yeah it's a lot for me it's
it's um doing the day plan before I
leave for the office for the next day
I'm having a bit of a weekly review or
putting down like what the weekly
objectives are before Monday starts
absolutely that that's absolutely huge
so okay so for the last like 10 15
minutes here then what I'd love to then
talk to you about is the the sort of
third piece that you've continued
involved in and more around business
overall and strategy
so I've got a couple of things that I'd
love to just just ask you around this
so firstly really curious
how what models do you operate in the
New York office in the American Market
do you have different models in terms of
you have a team of delivery Consultants
that do 180 and just follow on the focus
on the candidate side then you might
have account managers that just do
account management do you then have
people that just win new business and
sales or do you or do you typically
operate in a model where everyone is 360
and and people are responsible for
bringing their own clients and
um yeah and also the the candidate piece
like how do you think about that because
there's definitely I don't know that in
the UK there's definitely some really
interesting conversations happening
where I think a lot of people over the
last two years really double down on the
delivery model the 118 model
um and then I think over the last three
to six months with the shift in the
markets and their teams needed to be
more self-sufficient and winning their
own business people are starting to
maybe track back a bit or want more of
their teams to be able to win their own
business so how how has that played out
for you how do you think about that at
the moment within your offices and got
that gun into next year absolutely so we
we have always been a 360 uh from a
model through and through
um we do have a uh a specific accounts
team that looks after essentially our
top 30 accounts globally
um these are you know accounts that are
generating you know seven figures plus
of Revenue and a certain amount of
placements a year allowed but for the
most part I'd say 99 of the business is
a 360 uh model outside that accounts
team
um I don't think that's going to change
for us right and I think it really helps
shape some of the best Consultants that
can interact on both sides of the coin
and it's also pretty fulfilling to be
able to see you know the candidate that
you sourced and potentially head hunted
now go through a process and manage that
process work with the client and and
just take it all the way all the way
through is much more rewarding than just
doing one aspect of the the puzzle
and a very quick question on that yep
because I'm in the The Learning
development world so one of the most
common areas that our customers ask for
help with when it comes to skill
development is business development so
just curious what's ended up being your
framework science behind
like Tech Kareem starting with faden and
then how long is it before he's he's
interacting with clients because a lot
of people this might be more specific to
the UK
um start on the candidate side and they
may not start the BD client development
side until like three months six months
if you're if you really double down on a
360 piece don't plan to change like
what's your science behind that do you
get the chronic exposure in week one
like because have you have you found
this did you have you ever found
yourself dealing with that where you
found like a cohort of people just put
clients on the pedestal worry about BD
because they maybe did just focus on the
candidate side initially like what yeah
just interested to get your thoughts on
that absolutely so I think it's it is
very common for individuals to you know
put a client in pedestal and and psych
themselves out a bit about calling them
and interacting with them one of the
trainings that we do early on is is
almost a bit of a confidence boost
training just yeah at the end of the day
we're dealing with people a client is
still a person they're not going to bite
you it's going to be okay well let's
just let's get through it let's get them
on the phone let's get them for a coffee
and understand what they're about
um we get our consultants in the Weeds
on both sides of the coin clients from
candidates as early on as possible so it
could be within the first two weeks
um I think one of the things that we
have a bit of a luxury
um you know at fate is that we have such
a robust and seasoned book of business
with some of these clients so there's
opportunities for us to do a bit of you
know Brownfield Business Development
with warm and existing clients that we
can go and tap into and a more Junior
client can get a little bit softer
exposure to dealing with a pretty
seasoned or senior figure out a business
um and then on the other side we have
the the Greenfield business development
of going out and hunting and approaching
clients for the first time and you know
just going in cold with you know a basic
elevator pitch as to what we're about
um
I do think it's important to have both
experiences to really get good at the
Art and Science of doing quality
Business Development
yeah interesting and then I guess the
other thing that I want to um get your
thoughts on obviously you've been
operating in the obviously American
Market your whole career no so have you
always specifically focused on North
America correct yeah
so I I'd be interested to get your
thoughts on this obviously you guys have
UK business but have you so one of the
trends over the last two years 100 is
that there's been a real increase in UK
recruitment companies doing the US
marketing either only doing the US
market from the UK or it becoming a
really solid part of their business plan
so in your and and the reason why is
just a bit just add a bit of nuance the
UK so there's more UK recruitment
businesses in the UK than there is an
entire of the states right which is
absolutely [ __ ] nuts yeah so just to
put that into context because we shared
this on our live podcast event the other
week so there's basically there's yeah
there's more UK recruitment companies in
the US all in all
um and the UK can fit in Texas at the
whole of Newcastle like that some crazy
style I just put this into perspective
right
so have you found has things start to
become more competitive like how have
you I don't know what have you found
that I don't know obviously fading it's
different right like you said you you
guys have worked absolutely like so hard
over however many years to build the
reputation you have but obviously one of
the things you do is look at new markets
and have people go into new markets
these things have you found that it has
started to become more competitive than
maybe you've experienced in the past I'm
just just curious from your perspective
again I I don't I don't think so
um and not to sound you know about it in
an arrogant way or anything like that
that's not how it means to come up but
the the markets that we're in are are
extremely Niche and we focus on such
particular segments of the market where
there may not be one main competitor to
cover a whole you know slew of of
business right down I don't think for
example with Selby Jennings I don't
think there's one sole competitor to
Selby James for the seven eight markets
that we covered there are smaller
businesses that may compete with this
one team or this one desk
um
but again it's it's almost Apple sarges
in terms of the offering that that's
being provided
um yes there's definitely a boatload of
new uh names and faces that I've seen
pop up across the board but they don't
necessarily directly compete with what
we do because of the sheer set scale and
size excuse me uh that we're at now
tends to deliver at a different pace and
rate and caliber
yeah of course I was just curious if it
starts to come up in your meetings maybe
like you know how it is your guys or
girls go in oh this is the second time
I've called this type of business and
I've heard this company name I haven't
heard so that's interesting what about I
wanna I'm just going to put a pin on the
niche piece because like we hear this a
lot on this podcast so I definitely want
to get your your take on like what Niche
means to you yeah and how you look at
that but really quickly again just on
the sort of Optics and your perspective
of the the particularly the North
American Market what what states are you
excited by in terms of like going into
2023 next couple of years growth
opportunities obviously I know you're
going to talk about from the markets
that you guys operate in but yeah what
what states are you excited by the where
you you're you're you're really excited
with the the potential growth
um opportunities in the Estates yeah so
from from a state perspective and where
we currently have offices I'm you know
absolutely you know buzzing about
um you know like my colleague Dylan
Penny and and the LA office that they're
growing out there
um I think it was our fastest and and
hottest office launch uh sorry yeah la
yeah correct
um and that was I think the best office
launch that we had
um out of any you know uh launch in the
in the history of fading
um I think that the southeast is just a
promising place right now as well so
across Tampa Charlotte for us is is
going to be two areas of substantial
growth across a number of different
verticals not just you know one area in
particular
um and then Dallas right you see how
much is going on there just the sheer
real estate prices just you know
absolute hockey stick on a graph in
terms of growth down there and
businesses moving there so I would say
those three regions the South the west
coast and the southeast I think are
probably
primed for the most growth in terms of
we're going to see a lot of volume of
deal flow and placements there
yeah nice so yeah before before we
finish then yeah like talk talk to me
about how what how does cream view Niche
like what does that mean like for you
what yeah what makes a niche a niche if
you get what I mean because I think
everyone can sometimes think about this
differently so just always curious like
you said like that's clearly been a real
um solid part of the recipe as to why
you guys have been successful thanks to
talk to us about how you um explain and
describe Niche yeah so for me Niche is
going to be a specific
business critical
Market vertical and that's one of the
things that we really differentiate
ourselves on is and you can have a niche
you know function that is pretty
particular right you can maybe take like
a convertible bonds Trader right it's a
very small Market niche in a very small
area now
is that the most business critical role
to a financial institution maybe it is
for someone maybe it's for others right
what we for me what I what I'd like to
see is business critical functions Niche
business functions where those roles
don't go out of style where the markets
are going up down or sideways those
roles are constantly in demand that's
the type of Niche that I that I like to
go after that we go after
I really like that business critical
you're not going to ask you now don't
you Yep
this has obviously been what you've had
to get really good at right yep
what are some of the leading indicators
or like what is it that you really make
sure that Niche or vertical has that
makes you feel confident that it is
business critical
yeah absolutely so
we tend to follow
the the candidates in a sense right and
understand where where or candidates
going what are clients asking for and
and demanding uh we basically want to be
in in markets where the supply demand
imbalance for talent is always at a
constant rate
that that's I think the the main leading
indicator of that
um how a space is doing right we'll look
at our leading indicators and leading
Educators and internally of Are We
pulling you know a significant amount of
roles there is there space for us to
grow let's actually do some research and
understand you know what's the market
cap and and space that we have to run in
that region or sorry in that uh map
trailer vertical uh and a culmination of
all those things will then dictate
what that Niche will be or if that's
going to be an issue you want to go into
yeah I love it right final question then
Karim uh is what is it I'd love to hear
like what it is because I'm sure you're
thinking about this right now this part
of the year what are you and your team
and your your uh business function
doubling down on 20 in 2023 what what
are you guys really doubling down on
going into next year it could be
anything from uh yeah so just overall
yeah what you guys make sure you double
down on yeah I think for
for me here in New York the most
exciting piece that that we have is
technology uh
and from a more industry agnostic
approach I'd say that's where I'd like
to put a lot of
um you know my eggs into that basket
regardless of what's going on the market
and you know a lot of turmoil within you
know uh the startup worlds and and
whatnot I think the tech sector is one
that is just a behemoth and there's so
much potential and there's so many small
pockets and verticals that we've yet to
explore so I really want to double down
on growing that piece quite aggressively
love that well look Kareem it's been an
absolute pleasure I think kudos to you
sir on on building the career that you
have done I'm excited to see how it
continues to evolve from afar but yeah
thank you for being honest sharing a lot
of yeah I guess your philosophies
principles and uh yeah as I said uh
really appreciate you uh coming on the
show call me I appreciate as well thanks
so much for having me thank you so much
for listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
[Music]